des photographes photographier et qui
plus est à poil
il fallait oser ils se sont juste caché
derrière un slogan
quitte à être mise à poil par le cos
vider le gouvernement je préfère le
faire moi même
c'est ce qu'il s'est dit coralie madère
cette photographe s'affiche elle aussi
dans le plus simple appareil
on est dans une période compliquée le
moral est au plus bas un faux-pas faut
pas le cacher le moral était au plus bas
on a l'impression qu'on a un peu les
oubliés le fait de mettre tout nu et
puis d'avoir d'avoir ces postures
c'était vraiment symbolique montrer
montre effectivement que contourner ça à
la dérision mais en même temps un mais
fallait un message fort pour que pour
que ça interpelle s'afficher avec humour
pour protester se faire entendre pour
ses commerces non essentiels 2020 est
une année très compliquée privés
d'activités ils sont privés de revenus
et ils s'inquiètent pour leur avenir
on a été confinés durant deux mois quand
on a pu rouvrir nos portes
on aurait dû faire les saisons mariage
donc tous les mariages du moins la
plupart ont dû être reportés
actuellement c'est la période où on est
censé faire les séances de noël et
concrètement on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas les faire pourtant tout est mis en
place pour pour accueillir les clients
dans les meilleures conditions d'hygiène
les meilleures conditions pour leur
sécurité pour la nôtre aussi
dans cette société qui fait de
l'événementiel
les salariés ont rejoint le mouvement et
pris la pose aussi qu'ils soient
entrepreneurs commerçants ou artisans
tous espèrent pouvoir retravailler
bientôt